INTRO:
Remember Evergrande?
In late September and early October of last
year, they were the star of financial news.
Everyone was worried about what would happen
if this massive Chinese institution defaulted
on their debt and the ripple effects that
it would have on the world.
We saw headlines like “Fed warns China's
property problems could hurt global markets
and the US economy” and “Wall Street marks
biggest drop since May as Evergrande crisis
intensifies”.
Yet, as the fed started raising interest rates
and the stock market started to sell off for
other reasons, it seems that most people have
completely forgotten about this once monumental
threat.
This isn’t to say that the Evergrande situation
can be completely ignored though as the crisis
has only gotten worse.
In fact, at the end of last year, Evergrade
defaulted on $1.2 billion worth of foreign
bonds.
And as you would guess, their stock price
has only fallen further and further into abyss
standing at just 17 cents today.
So, whatever happened to the Evergrande crisis,
and does Evergrande even matter on a world
scale?
THE BIRTH OF EVERGRANDE:
Before we get into the potential consequences
of the Evergrande crisis, let’s first take
a look at how this crisis even formed in the
first place.
This wasn’t something that just took place
over a matter of years.
Rather, this issue has actually been brewing
for decades going all the way back to the
1970s.
You see, in 1978, the Chinese government adopted
a new economic policy that many scholars call
“China’s Open Door Policy”.
Before this ideology was adopted, China was
completely closed off to the world economy.
They practiced an ideology called “zhong
xue wei ti, xi xue wei yong” which translates
to "Chinese Learning as Substance, Western
Learning for Application" As the name suggests,
China was intent on maintaining their traditional
culture as well as their communist political
and economic system.
However, they were willing to import technology
from the west and implement it into their
society.
While this strategy worked decently for much
of the 1900s, it came with a slew of shortfalls.
First of all, China was barely involved in
foreign trade, and secondly, no one wanted
to invest in China which made it increasingly
difficult to keep up with the west.
Not to mention, China’s economic and political
landscape had been devasted by the Cultural
Revolution which took place between 1966 and
1976.
So, in 1978, China finally gave in and adopted
the “Open Door Policy”.
Things didn’t just change overnight though.
China spent years deciding which sectors they
needed to control and which sectors they could
loosen up.
China was by no means willing to give up land
ownership, but they were willing to privatize
how the land was used and this brings us to
the Amendment Act of 1988.
This amendment made it possible for companies
and individuals to use land to their liking
by obtaining land use rights.
This opened the door to a wide number of entrepreneurs
who were looking to build real estate and
property development companies.
As you would guess, Evergrande’s founder,
Xu Jiayin, fell under this category.
Xu was actually a bit late to this trend as
he didn’t start Evergrande till 1996 which
is 8 years after the amendment was adopted.
Nonetheless, Evergrande would leverage this
new opportunity to the max and the company
would grow exponentially over the next two
decades.
Evergrande’s growth was only further accelerated
by new China joining the World Trade Organization
in 2001.
This made Chinese investments more appealing
than ever before which allowed Evergrande
to grow an international base of investors
and stake holders.
Ironically, Evergrande actually went public
during the height of the great financial recession
in October of 2009.
But despite this, they were still able to
raise $722 million which just goes to show
how much interest their was in Chinese real
estate amongst international investors.
All of these factors would allow Evergrade
to become one of the largest property developers
in China and one of the biggest companies
in world.
In fact, the company was and still is part
of the Global 500 coming in at rank 122.
This monumental growth didn’t come for free
though.
Evergrande was constantly taking on more and
more risk which would eventually come to back
haunt them.
GHOST CITIES:
One of the biggest risks of the Chinese real
estate market over the past 2 decades has
been the ever growing real estate bubble.
One of the most famous examples of this is
the dozens of ghost cities located across
China.
If you’re not familiar with China’s ghost
cities, these are essentially massive developments
that never became inhabited.
Oftentimes, you see dozens of skyscrapers
and buildings that are completely empty and
sometimes not even finished.
Now, you might be wondering, how in the world
do these ghost cities even form in the first
place?
Well, if we take a look at Chinese real estate
law, we’ll quickly begin to understand how
exactly this happened.
China separates real estate developments into
a few different categories starting with economically
affordable housing.
China requires that such projects are occupied
by the owner and these projects cannot be
bought or sold as an investment.
On top of this, real estate companies cannot
sell these properties for more than 5% over
the construction cost.
So, these projects aren’t particularly lucrative
or appealing.
One category that is super appealing, however,
is commodity housing which can be bought and
sold as an investment in most cases.
And in China, there’s extraordinary demand
for real estate.
Real estate is often thought of the best way
to grow generational wealth, so even many
middle class families opt to buy 2nd and 3rd
properties as soon as they can afford it.
Also, China has yet to experience a 2008 style
housing market collapse, so as far as the
everyday Chinese person knows, real estate
prices only go up.
And, honestly, this is not a bad bet.
Even if there is a crash, it’s just a matter
of time until real estate recovers because
people will always need land.
But, here’s the problem, you can’t own
land in China.
So, if you want a piece of real estate in
an area that you think will develop in 20
to 30 years, you have to build something on
it right now.
And when millions of Chinese people are thinking
the same thing, it doesn’t take long to
garner enough demand to build an entire ghost
city.
So, while these cities are indeed mostly if
not completely empty, they’re also completely
sold out.
This has provided Chinese real estate developers
with unprecedented demand.
But when all of your demand comes from investors
and not people who are looking for a primary
residence, it just takes one market downturn
to obliterate your demand.
TURNING A BLIND EYE:
But, wait a minute, there’s no way the Chinese
government didn’t see what was happening
right?
How did they not think to stop this unsustainable
practice?
Well, the answer is two fold.
First of all, local governments are super
incentivized to sell land rights to these
development companies.
You see, municipal governments only get keep
about 40% of the country’s tax revenue.
The rest must be passed on to the CCP.
However, local governments have to pay for
80% of their expenses.
So, local governments have to do something
to overcome this funding disparity, and the
easiest answer for them has been selling land
rights.
In 2015, for instance, land transferring fees
accounted for 40-60% of local government revenue.
This is not that surprising when you consider
that land sales brought in $438 billion for
local governments in 2012.
I don’t think I need to explain why local
governments were a fan of ghost cities, but
what about the CCP.
Surely, they could see how this was a massive
bubble waiting to blow up right?
Well, they did, and they would eventually
take action, but now before letting the situation
get too far out of hand.
You see, the CCP was also massively incentivized
to turn a blind eye to these ghost cities.
The CCP wasn’t directly pulling in cash
from land sales like local governments, but
they were able to pump up the Chinese GDP.
The Chinese real estate industry accounts
for 29% of the entire country’s GDP.
So, letting these ghost cities pop up was
extremely beneficial in terms of catching
up and beating the US in terms of GDP.
At first, this wasn’t a big issue as real
estate developers were pretty responsible
financially.
But, it didn’t take long for greed to kick
for developers like Evergrande.
They started taking out substantially more
debt, and their debt to equity ratio fell
off a cliff.
For example, in 2014, Evergrande had ¥112
billion in equity and ¥206 billion in assets.
This gave them an extremely healthy debt to
equity ratio of 0.839 meaning that they had
more equity than debt.
By 2020, their equity had grown to ¥350 billion
which sounds good until you realize that their
assets had grown to ¥2.3 trillion.
This results in a super dangerous debt to
equity ratio of 5.57.
If Evergrande was an average American, they
would’ve had to take out PMI or private
mortgage insurance because they didn’t even
have 20% equity.
This issue wasn’t just limited to Evergrande
either.
Many Chinese real estate companies were in
similar positions which made it abundantly
clear to the CCP that they had to take action.
TOO LITTLE TOO LATE:
In August of 2020, Chinese regulators met
with the country’s largest real estate companies
including Evergrande and they introduced three
restrictions called the three red lines.
These restrictions put caps on three debt
ratios which were debt to cash, debt to equity,
and debt to assets.
As you would guess, Evergrande didn’t exactly
fall within these restrictions, so they would
start selling off properties and raising cash.
For example, in September of 2020, they discounted
properties by 30% to increase sales.
Similarly, in October, they raised $555 million
by completing a share offering.
They also cancelled certain projects, but
none of this was enough to improve their financial
situation substantially.
Nonetheless, Evergrande was able to stay afloat
thanks to sufficient cashflow, but it didn’t
take long for this to go downhill as well.
In late 2020, Jack Ma and the CCP would get
into a bit of a conundrum which prompted the
CCP to crackdown on Chinese tech companies.
While most of the CCPs actions were directly
targetted towards tech companies, as tech
stocks crumbled, so did investor confidence.
And as investors started pulling back on real
estate investments, Evergrande’s net profit
started to decline as well.
In August of 2021, Evergrande reported a 29%
year over year decline in net profit.
And given Evergrande’s already fragile position,
this was enough for default fears to go rampant.
Evergrande continued to insist that while
they were facing issues, there was nothing
to worry about.
You could say that these were their famous
last words as Evergrande would miss their
first set of coupon payments just a few weeks
later.
Shortly after, Evergrande would begin missing
coupon payments on a regular basis until they
eventually defaulted on $1.2 billion worth
of debt.
CCP TO THE RESCUE:
The CCP has never publicly acknowledged that
they’re bailing out Evergrande, but that’s
basically what they’ve been doing.
They’re not exactly saving the company itself,
but they’re trying their best to ensure
that the collapse of Evergrande does not lead
further consequences.
And the main way their accomplishing this
is by nationalizing the company.
For example, local governments have been seizing
rights granted to Evergrande.
Similarly, China’s central bank freed up
$188 billion to help alleviate any liquidity
problems caused by Evergrande’s default.
Evergrande has also been selling parts of
their own business to raise cash and pay off
debt.
So, at this point, it does look like China
has Evergrande under control and that they’ll
be able to contain the crisis, but only time
will tell.
Do you think the Evergrande crisis is behind
us or is it just a preview as to what’s
to come?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you think the ghost cities
are spooky.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.